If it's a flat or a squeal, a wobble or peel, your tread's worn down or you need a new wheel, wherever you go, you can get a pro at TreadExperts. For exceptional traction on snow and ice, trust Continental Tires Viking Contact 7 Tire. And right now, get a $100 rebate with select Continental Tires. Find a Continental TreadExperts dealer near you at treadexperts.ca slash locations. From tires to auto repair, we're always there at treadexperts.ca slash locations. From tires to auto repair we're always there at treadexperts.ca It's been four years since I first learned about the disappearance of Neum May, an 18 year old who went missing from the small New South Wales town of Batlow back in 2002. I don't know if it's because Neyam and I finished high school in the same year, or we shared a similar taste in music, but I felt instinctively drawn to her story. As I learned more about Neyam's story, the revelations that unfolded left me in shock. The result is Missing
无论是爆胎还是尖叫，车轮晃动或外皮脱落，胎面磨损或需要更换新轮，无论您去往何处，TreadExperts 的专业人员都能为您提供服务。若想在冰雪路面上获得卓越的抓地力，请信赖德国马牌 Viking Contact 7 轮胎。现在购买指定马牌轮胎，还可获得 100 美元的返利。请访问 treadexperts.ca/locations 查找您附近的 Continental TreadExperts 经销商。从轮胎到汽车维修，我们始终在 treadexperts.ca/locations 为您服务。从轮胎到汽车维修，我们始终在 treadexperts.ca 为您服务。距离我第一次听说 Neum May 失踪已经过去四年了，这位 18 岁的女孩于 2002 年在新南威尔士州的小镇巴特洛（Batlow）失踪。我不知道是因为 Neyam 和我同年高中毕业，还是我们有着相似的音乐品味，但我本能地被她的故事所吸引。随着我对 Neyam 故事了解的深入，随之而来的真相让我感到震惊。结果就是《失踪》
Neyam, the latest 12-part series from Casefile Presents. Researched and hosted by me, the series features exclusive interviews with key players who help us dive into the details of Neyem's case as we go back to Batlo to try and make sense of what really happened. The entire 12-part series is available now. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At around 3am on Sunday August 19 1990, 35-year-old Rudy Manuel was awoken by a strange sound.
《Neyam》是 Casefile Presents 推出的最新 12 集系列节目。该系列由我进行研究并担任主持，通过对关键人物的独家采访，帮助我们深入了解 Neyam 案件的细节，并带我们回到巴特洛，试图弄清到底发生了什么。完整的 12 集系列现已上线。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。1990 年 8 月 19 日星期日凌晨 3 点左右，35 岁的 Rudy Manuel 被一阵奇怪的声音惊醒。
Rudy Manuel was awoken by a strange sound. As the long-time caretaker of the Camp Nelson Lodge, a 42-acre bucolic retreat in central California's sprawling and isolated Sequoia and Redwood forests, Rudy was intuitively familiar with his surroundings. When horses in a nearby pasture began stirring restlessly in the middle of the night, Rudy sensed something or someone was out there. Rudy opened the door of the rustic cabin where he had been sleeping and looked outside. If something was lurking, Rudy couldn't see it through the pitch black darkness. He closed the door and locked it, turned off the lights, and crawled back into bed. Rudy wasn't alone. Lying next to him was 46-year-old Bonnie Hood, the owner and manager of the Camp Nelson Lodge. Five minutes later, the bedroom light suddenly turned on. It took a moment for Rudy's eyes to
Rudy Manuel 被一阵奇怪的声音惊醒。作为尼尔森营地旅馆（Camp Nelson Lodge）的长期管理员，Rudy 对这个位于加利福尼亚州中部广阔而偏僻的红杉和红木森林中、占地 42 英亩的田园式度假胜地非常熟悉。当附近牧场的马匹在深夜开始不安地躁动时，Rudy 直觉地感觉到外面有什么东西或什么人。Rudy 打开了他睡觉的乡村小屋的门，向外望去。如果有什么东西潜伏在外面，Rudy 在漆黑的夜色中也看不见。他关上门并锁好，关掉灯，爬回床上。Rudy 并不孤单。躺在他身边的是 46 岁的 Bonnie Hood，她是尼尔森营地旅馆的所有者兼经理。五分钟后，卧室的灯突然亮了。Rudy 花了一会儿时间才
adjust and for him to realise that an unfamiliar person was standing over him. The intruder was aiming a snub-nosed.38 calibre revolver directly at Rudy's head. The man ordered Rudy to get off the bed and kneel on the floor. Rudy defiantly responded, if you want me on the floor, you're going to have to put me down. Without hesitation, the gunman pulled the trigger, shooting Rudy in the forehead. As Rudy's body slumped to the ground, the gunman turned his attention to Bonnie Hood, demanding, where's the money? Bonnie replied in a panic, it's in the lodge. Bonnie was then shot as she cowered in bed. Even though the bullet had pierced Rudy Manuel's skull and left fragments in his brain, he was still alive.
适应过来，并意识到一个陌生人正站在他上方。入侵者用一把短管 .38 口径左轮手枪直接瞄准了 Rudy 的头部。那人命令 Rudy 下床跪在地上。Rudy 挑衅地回答说：“如果你想让我趴在地上，你就得先把我打倒。”枪手毫不犹豫地扣动了扳机，击中了 Rudy 的前额。当 Rudy 的身体瘫倒在地时，枪手将注意力转向 Bonnie Hood，质问道：“钱在哪里？”Bonnie 惊慌地回答说：“在旅馆里。”随后，Bonnie 在蜷缩在床上时被枪杀。尽管子弹穿透了 Rudy Manuel 的头骨并在他的大脑中留下了碎片，但他仍然活着。
Blood ran down his face, his ears rang painfully, and the taste of gunpowder lingered in his mouth. Rudy pretended to be dead until the gunman left. He then slowly crawled across the floor into the living area where he reached for a telephone. Using what little strength Rudy had left, he dialled 911. The history of the Camp Nelson township dates back to 1886 when its founder, John Nelson, built a homestead on the land. Before long, his ranch became a popular destination for hunters, fishermen, and anyone else willing to make the journey into the mountains by horseback. By the early 20th century, Camp Nelson had grown into a thriving, albeit small community, with a hotel and a general store that drew an influx of new visitors to the area.
鲜血顺着他的脸流下，他的耳朵里发出痛苦的嗡嗡声，嘴里还残留着火药味。Rudy 假装死亡，直到枪手离开。然后，他慢慢地爬过地板进入起居区，伸手去拿电话。Rudy 用尽最后一点力气拨打了 911。尼尔森营地镇的历史可以追溯到 1886 年，当时其创始人 John Nelson 在这片土地上建造了一处宅基地。不久之后，他的牧场就成了猎人、渔民以及任何愿意骑马前往山区的人们的热门目的地。到了 20 世纪初，尼尔森营地已经发展成为一个繁荣但规模很小的社区，拥有一家旅馆和一家杂货店，吸引了大量新游客来到该地区。
Bonnie Hood first visited Camp Nelson in 1952 when she was eight years old. By then, the centrepiece of the town was a massive stone and timber lodge built by John Nelson's grandson. Featuring a grand dining hall and an impressive great room with two enormous fireplaces, the magnificent Camp Nelson Lodge served as the town's de facto community centre for almost every important event. Bonnie and her family visited Camp Nelson every summer, and she carried on the tradition when she started a family of her own. However, as time went on, the lodge was plagued by financial woes, leading to its closure in January 1981. In the summer of 1987, Bonnie and her husband Jim noticed a for-sale sign out in front of the
Bonnie Hood 第一次访问尼尔森营地是在 1952 年，当时她才八岁。那时，小镇的核心是一座由 John Nelson 的孙子建造的巨大的石木结构旅馆。宏伟的尼尔森营地旅馆拥有一个大餐厅和一个带有两个巨大壁炉的令人印象深刻的大厅，几乎是镇上举办所有重要活动的非官方社区中心。Bonnie 和她的家人每年夏天都会去尼尔森营地，当她自己组建家庭后，她也延续了这一传统。然而，随着时间的推移，旅馆陷入了财务困境，导致其于 1981 年 1 月关闭。1987 年夏天，Bonnie 和她的丈夫 Jim 注意到旅馆前挂着一块待售招牌。
lodge. While the couple initially joked with each other about buying the property, they ultimately decided to make a serious offer. Their offer of $780,000 was accepted and by June 1988, Bonnie and Jim Hood were the new owners of the Camp Nelson Lodge. Even though Bonnie had been visiting the area since she was a child, many of the town's 180 residents viewed the lodge's new owners with scepticism. To them, the Hoods were outsiders, wealthy metropolitan interlopers who threatened to change the fabric of their community. Others were excited by the prospect of the lodge being restored to its former glory.
虽然这对夫妇最初只是开玩笑说要买下这处房产，但他们最终决定提出正式报价。他们 78 万美元的报价被接受了，到 1988 年 6 月，Bonnie 和 Jim Hood 成为了尼尔森营地旅馆的新主人。尽管 Bonnie 从小就经常来这里，但镇上 180 名居民中的许多人对旅馆的新主人持怀疑态度。对他们来说，Hood 一家是外来者，是威胁要改变他们社区结构的富有的大都市闯入者。其他人则对旅馆恢复昔日辉煌的前景感到兴奋。
In order to revive and operate the lodge full time, Bonnie relocated to Camp Nelson and moved into one of the cabins. Her husband Jim and their two teenage children remained at their home in Newport Beach, nearly four and a half hours' drive away. The unconventional arrangement drew judgement among townsfolk, as did some of Bonnie's other decisions. While the locals were initially thrilled when the lodger's restaurant and bar reopened. They were dismayed when Bonnie raised the prices. Others boycotted the establishment altogether when Bonnie kicked them out for being too rowdy. When Bonnie built fences for her horses, some of her neighbours complained they blocked access to their properties. She also caused a stir for being an outspoken environmentalist working to expose what she believed were illegal
为了全面恢复和经营旅馆，Bonnie 搬到了尼尔森营地，住进了其中一间小屋。她的丈夫 Jim 和他们的两个十几岁的孩子留在了距离这里近四个半小时车程的纽波特海滩家中。这种非传统的安排引起了镇民的议论，Bonnie 的一些其他决定也是如此。虽然当地人在旅馆的餐厅和酒吧重新开业时最初感到非常高兴，但当 Bonnie 提高价格时，他们感到非常失望。当 Bonnie 因为当地人太吵闹而将他们赶出去时，其他人则完全抵制了这家店。当 Bonnie 为她的马建造围栏时，一些邻居抱怨说这阻碍了他们进入自己的房产。她还因为是一名直言不讳的环保主义者而引起了轰动，她致力于揭露她认为在该地区存在的非法
logging practices in the area. As one employee who worked for Bonnie told the Fresno Bee, Bonnie answered to no one and apologized to no one. But what upset locals most was Bonnie's plan to turn the lodge into a trendy venue for lavish destination weddings and a high-end luxury retreat catering to wealthy clientele from Los Angeles. In their view, the whole point of going to Camp Nelson was to get away from the fast-paced city lifestyle in the first place. While some felt Bonnie harboured a combative LA attitude that conflicted with Camp Nelson's breezy, carefree way of life, others were less critical of her. One local told the Fresno Bee that the majority view of Bonnie was that she was a cheerful, outgoing person who spent an enormous amount of time, money and energy bringing Camp Nelson Lodge back to life.
伐木行为。正如一位为 Bonnie 工作的员工告诉《弗雷斯诺蜜蜂报》（Fresno Bee）的那样，Bonnie 不对任何人负责，也不向任何人道歉。但最让当地人不满的是 Bonnie 的计划，她想把旅馆变成一个时尚的场所，用于举办奢华的目的地婚礼，并将其打造为一个高端豪华度假胜地，以迎合来自洛杉矶的富有客户。在他们看来，去尼尔森营地的全部意义首先就是为了远离快节奏的城市生活方式。虽然有些人觉得 Bonnie 带有与尼尔森营地轻松、无忧无虑的生活方式相冲突的洛杉矶式好斗态度，但其他人对她的批评较少。一位当地人告诉《弗雷斯诺蜜蜂报》，大多数人对 Bonnie 的看法是，她是一个开朗、外向的人，花费了大量的时间、金钱和精力让尼尔森营地旅馆重获新生。
On Saturday August 18 1990, a high society wedding and reception was held at the lodge. The bride was thrilled with the venue and wept tears of joy while complimenting Bonnie on how wonderful everything had been. It was welcomed reinforcement that Bonnie's vision for the lodge was coming to fruition. While the wedding was taking place at the lodge, its restaurant and bar remained open to the public, making it far busier than a regular Saturday night. When live music started during the wedding reception, some locals at the bar joined in the festivities. The reception concluded just before midnight, but the bar stayed open serving locals until 2am.
1990 年 8 月 18 日星期六，一场上流社会的婚礼和招待会在旅馆举行。新娘对场地非常满意，流下了喜悦的泪水，并称赞 Bonnie 把一切都安排得如此美妙。这是一种受欢迎的肯定，证明了 Bonnie 对旅馆的愿景正在实现。当婚礼在旅馆举行时，其餐厅和酒吧仍然对公众开放，这使得它比普通的周六晚上要繁忙得多。当婚礼招待会上开始播放现场音乐时，酒吧里的一些当地人也加入了庆祝活动。招待会在午夜前结束，但酒吧一直营业到凌晨 2 点，为当地人提供服务。
At the end of the evening, Bonnie pulled all the tips her wait staff had collected during their shifts. Usually, she split the tips evenly before sending her staff home. But because there was much more money than usual, approximately $500, she decided to take the money back to her cabin. She promised to count it and pay out her employees the next morning. Just over an hour later, first responders arrived at Bonnie's cabin after receiving the 911 call from Rudy Manuel. They trepidatiously entered and turned on the lights. They immediately saw Rudy's body on the floor of the living room, covered in carpet burns
晚上结束时，Bonnie 收取了服务员在轮班期间收到的所有小费。通常，她会在让员工回家之前平分小费。但由于钱比平时多得多，大约有 500 美元，她决定把钱带回她的小屋。她承诺第二天早上清点并支付给员工。一个多小时后，在接到 Rudy Manuel 的 911 报警电话后，急救人员抵达了 Bonnie 的小屋。他们战战兢兢地走进去并打开了灯。他们立即看到 Rudy 的尸体躺在客厅的地板上，身上覆盖着地毯灼伤
and blood. He had been shot in the head. A trail of blood led from where Rudy lay and into the bedroom, ending by the bed. Laying on top, half covered by a blanket and sheet, was Bonnie Hood. She had been fatally shot in the head. It appeared her body had been posed afterwards, with her arms crossed over her chest as if she were laid in a casket. One of the screens on an exterior sliding door had been cut open. The same door featured pry marks indicating the killer had
和血迹。他的头部中弹。一条血迹从 Rudy 躺着的地方一直延伸到卧室，在床边结束。躺在上面，被毯子和床单半遮盖着的是 Bonnie Hood。她的头部被致命地击中。她的身体似乎在事后被摆放过，双臂交叉在胸前，就像被安放在棺材里一样。外部滑动门上的一个纱窗被割开了。同一扇门上有撬痕，表明凶手
used a tool to force his way inside. In the dirt outside was a single shoe print left by the killer. a single shoe print left by the killer. Aside from this, the only other major clue was found inside the cabin. As Rudy Manuel had clung to life, he used his finger to scroll two letters on a wall in his own blood. J and B. Police were well aware of a near two decade long feud between Rudy Manuel and a local cattle rancher named Jack Burgess. Rudy was a Native American who had grown up on a reservation a few miles south of Camp Nelson. From the time he was a teenager, Rudy had been a thorn in Jack Burgess' side. His cattle ranch bordered the reservation and Jack had accused Rudy of vandalising his property many times over the years. He also once accused Rudy of shooting at him.
使用了工具强行进入。外面的泥地上留下了凶手的一枚鞋印。除此之外，唯一的另一个主要线索是在小屋内发现的。当 Rudy Manuel 在垂死挣扎时，他用手指在墙上用自己的血写下了两个字母：J 和 B。警方非常清楚 Rudy Manuel 与当地一位名叫 Jack Burgess 的养牛场主之间长达近二十年的积怨。Rudy 是一名美洲原住民，在尼尔森营地以南几英里的保留地长大。从十几岁起，Rudy 就一直是 Jack Burgess 的眼中钉。他的养牛场与保留地接壤，Jack 多年来曾多次指控 Rudy 破坏他的财产。他还曾指控 Rudy 向他开枪。
Rudy had a chequered history with convictions for horse stealing, vandalism and assault. Struggling to find employment or a place to live, Rudy was given an opportunity to work for Bonnie Hood after she purchased the Camp Nelson Lodge in 1988. The following year, Rudy was arrested after trying to sell five of Jack Burgess' calves to another rancher. Facing a potential six-month jail sentence, Rudy found a supporter in Bonny Hood. She paid for his defence attorney and the case against Rudy was ultimately dismissed. This angered Jack Burgess, who expressed his opinion that the police and judge were corrupt. Things only escalated when Rudy smashed the windshield of Jack's truck with a baseball bat.
Rudy 有着斑斑劣迹，曾因偷马、破坏公物和袭击他人而被定罪。由于难以找到工作或住所，Rudy 在 Bonnie Hood 于 1988 年买下尼尔森营地旅馆后获得了为她工作的机会。第二年，Rudy 在试图将 Jack Burgess 的五头小牛卖给另一位牧场主后被捕。面临可能长达六个月的监禁，Rudy 在 Bonnie Hood 那里得到了支持。她为他支付了辩护律师的费用，针对 Rudy 的案件最终被驳回。这激怒了 Jack Burgess，他表示认为警察和法官都是腐败的。当 Rudy 用棒球棍砸碎 Jack 卡车的挡风玻璃时，事情进一步升级。
On Tuesday June 19 1990, exactly two months before the shooting, Rudy suffered an appendicitis attack. Bonnie drove him to the hospital and as she pulled into the parking lot, she noticed that Jack Burgess happened to be there too. Not paying him any mind, she took Rudy into the emergency department. Upon returning to her car, Bonnie noticed a handwritten note attached to her windshield. It read, It is your head, not your windshield that I will get. Payback's a bitch, like your sugar mama. Bonnie believed that Jack Burgess had left the note for Rudy. She suspected she was the sugar mama referenced in the note, as she had previously paid for Rudy. She suspected she was the sugar mama referenced in the note, as she had previously paid for Rudy's attorney during his successful legal stoush against Jack.
1990 年 6 月 19 日星期二，即枪击事件发生前整整两个月，Rudy 突发阑尾炎。Bonnie 开车送他去医院，当她驶入停车场时，她注意到 Jack Burgess 恰好也在那里。她没理会他，带着 Rudy 进入了急诊室。回到车上时，Bonnie 注意到挡风玻璃上贴着一张手写的纸条。上面写着：“我要对付的是你的头，而不是你的挡风玻璃。报应是个婊子，就像你的糖妈一样。”Bonnie 认为 Jack Burgess 给 Rudy 留下了这张纸条。她怀疑自己就是纸条中提到的“糖妈”，因为她之前曾为 Rudy 支付过律师费。她怀疑自己就是纸条中提到的“糖妈”，因为她之前曾为 Rudy 在与 Jack 的成功法律纠纷中支付过律师费。
Bonnie filed a police report accusing Jack of authoring the note. Although Jack's fingerprints weren't found on it, detectives wondered if the shooting at Bonnie's cabin was the payback the note had forewarned. Miraculously, when first responders arrived at Bonnie's cabin after the shooting, Rudy Manuel was still alive. He was rushed to undergo emergency surgery to remove the bullet fragments from his brain. Right before Rudy was taken into the operating theatre, a detective questioned him about the attack. Drifting in and out of consciousness as he spoke, Rudy admitted that he and Bonnie were having an affair. After closing down the bar the previous night, Rudy said that he and Bonnie had gone back to her cabin and fallen asleep before they were confronted by the gunman.
Bonnie 向警方报案，指控 Jack 写了这张纸条。虽然上面没有发现 Jack 的指纹，但侦探们怀疑 Bonnie 小屋的枪击事件是否就是纸条预示的报应。奇迹般的是，当急救人员在枪击事件后抵达 Bonnie 的小屋时，Rudy Manuel 还活着。他被紧急送往医院进行手术，以取出大脑中的子弹碎片。就在 Rudy 被送进手术室之前，一名侦探询问了他关于袭击的事情。Rudy 在说话时意识时有时无，他承认他和 Bonnie 正在发生婚外情。Rudy 说，前一天晚上关掉酒吧后，他和 Bonnie 回到了她的小屋，在被枪手对峙之前就睡着了。
Rudy described the shooter as looking like a biker. He was a stocky white man in his mid-30s with long, curly blonde hair and a thin mustache. Rudy recalled he was wearing a neckerchief with the branding of US motorcycle company Harley Davidson. Several witnesses who had been at the lodger's bar that night recalled seeing a man matching this description, but no one knew who he was. They recalled that at one stage he requested a song from the musician at the wedding reception, and that he was the last customer at the bar come closing time. Most interestingly, the stranger was within earshot of a heated conversation Bonnie Hood had with one of her
Rudy 将枪手描述为看起来像个骑手。他是一个 30 多岁、身材魁梧的白人男子，留着长长的金色卷发，留着细细的胡子。Rudy 回忆说，他戴着一条印有美国摩托车公司哈雷戴维森（Harley Davidson）标志的颈巾。当晚在旅馆酒吧的几位目击者回忆说看到了一个符合此描述的男子，但没有人知道他是谁。他们回忆说，他在某个阶段曾向婚礼招待会上的音乐家点了一首歌，而且他是酒吧打烊时最后一位顾客。最有趣的是，这个陌生人在 Bonnie Hood 与她的一名员工进行激烈谈话时就在旁边，
employees about not splitting the tips until the following morning. This meant he was aware that Bonnie was in possession of a large amount of cash that she intended to take back to her cabin. Yet, although Bonnie's cabin was found in a slight state of disarray, it didn't appear to have been ransacked. Several expensive items of jewellery were left in plain sight, and $211 remained in her purse, which was visibly resting on a bar stool. Rudy Manuel claimed that the killer had demanded money, but nothing in Bonnie's cabin appeared to be missing. Prior to his surgery, Rudy expressed his own theory. He suspected that the killer was a professional hitman who had most likely been hired by his longtime rival, Jack Burgess. When Jack heard about this shooting, he immediately went to speak with police,
谈话内容是关于在第二天早上之前不平分小费。这意味着他知道 Bonnie 手里有大量现金，打算带回她的小屋。然而，虽然 Bonnie 的小屋被发现处于轻微的混乱状态，但似乎并没有被洗劫。几件昂贵的珠宝被留在显眼的地方，她的钱包里还剩下 211 美元，钱包就放在吧台凳上。Rudy Manuel 声称凶手索要钱财，但 Bonnie 小屋里似乎没有任何东西丢失。在手术前，Rudy 表达了他自己的理论。他怀疑凶手是一名职业杀手，很可能是由他的长期竞争对手 Jack Burgess 雇佣的。当 Jack 听说这次枪击事件时，他立即去与警方交谈，
as he knew he would be considered a suspect due to his volatile history with Rudy. Wanting to set the record straight as soon as possible, Jack denied any involvement in the crime and expressed his willingness to cooperate fully with the investigation. Although Jack provided a solid alibi for the night of the shooting, it was possible that he'd hired someone else to carry out the attack, as Rudy Manuel had theorised. Rudy's sister, Christina, worked part-time at the lodge. She recalled seeing the mysterious stranger at the bar the night of the shooting. Curiously, she had seen him the weekend before as well. She believed he had arrived at Camp Nelson to carry out construction work, specifically to put a new roof on one of the homes in town. As there were few residences in Camp Nelson and only one had a brand new roof,
因为他知道由于他与 Rudy 之间动荡的历史，他会被视为嫌疑人。为了尽快澄清事实，Jack 否认参与了犯罪，并表示愿意全力配合调查。虽然 Jack 为枪击当晚提供了可靠的不在场证明，但正如 Rudy Manuel 所推测的那样，他有可能雇佣了其他人来实施袭击。Rudy 的妹妹 Christina 在旅馆兼职。她回忆说在枪击当晚在酒吧看到了那个神秘的陌生人。奇怪的是，她前一个周末也见过他。她认为他来到尼尔森营地是为了进行建筑工作，具体来说是为镇上的一所房子安装新屋顶。由于尼尔森营地的住宅很少，而且只有一个有全新的屋顶，
investigators immediately knew where to start this new line of inquiry. The home belonged to a local attorney who told police that he had hired two brothers to do the job. Their names were Mark and Matthew Stewart and they were from the Californian city of Fresno. Mark and Matthew Stewart and they were from the Californian city of Fresno. Police tracked the Stewart brothers down and were discouraged to find that neither of the men matched descriptions of Bonny Hood's killer. As this lead seemingly reached a dead end, investigators were surprised when a man arrived at the Stewart brothers' home. He was a near perfect match for the description of Bonnie Hood and Rudy Manuel's shooter. He introduced himself as Rick Lomir and asserted that he had never been to Camp Nelson.
调查人员立即知道从哪里开始这条新的调查线索。这所房子属于一位当地律师，他告诉警方他雇佣了两兄弟来做这项工作。他们的名字是 Mark 和 Matthew Stewart，来自加利福尼亚州的弗雷斯诺市。Mark 和 Matthew Stewart 来自加利福尼亚州的弗雷斯诺市。警方追踪到了 Stewart 兄弟，但令人沮丧的是，这两个人都不符合 Bonnie Hood 杀手的描述。正当这条线索似乎陷入死胡同时，调查人员惊讶地发现一名男子来到了 Stewart 兄弟的家中。他与 Bonnie Hood 和 Rudy Manuel 的枪手描述几乎完全吻合。他自称是 Rick Lomir，并声称他从未去过尼尔森营地。
Meanwhile, Rudy Manuel had undergone life-saving surgery and and after three days recovering, he was able to hold a conversation again. However, his brain was swollen and he was delirious and heavily sedated. While Rudy couldn't offer investigators much at this time, he was shown a photo lineup that included an image of Rick Lomir. Rudy pointed to Rick's photo and identified him as the man who'd shot him and Bonnie. The problem was Rick provided an ironclad alibi for the night of the shooting, proving he was nowhere near Camp Nelson. Rudy Manuel had identified the wrong man. As Rudy recovered, he provided another account of the night of the shooting, this time to a psychiatrist.
与此同时，Rudy Manuel 接受了挽救生命的手术，在康复三天后，他又能进行交谈了。然而，他的大脑肿胀，神志不清，并服用了大量镇静剂。虽然 Rudy 当时无法向调查人员提供太多信息，但他被展示了一组照片，其中包括 Rick Lomir 的照片。Rudy 指着 Rick 的照片，认定他就是枪杀他和 Bonnie 的人。问题是 Rick 为枪击当晚提供了铁证如山的不在场证明，证明他当时根本不在尼尔森营地附近。Rudy Manuel 认错了人。随着 Rudy 的康复，他提供了关于枪击当晚的另一个说法，这次是向一位精神科医生提供的。
His version of events differed from what he'd originally told the police prior to his surgery. When the psychiatrist asked Rudy if he thought he was capable of identifying the shooter, Rudy shocked him by replying, You are the man that shot me. When the psychiatrist explained why this wasn't possible, Rudy said, Well, you look a lot like him. It was clear to detectives that Rudy wasn't well enough to be fully relied upon, but they began considering the possibility that he wasn't the intended target at all. Given Bonnie Hood's
他的事件版本与他在手术前最初告诉警察的版本不同。当精神科医生问 Rudy 是否认为自己有能力辨认出枪手时，Rudy 的回答让他大吃一惊：“你就是那个开枪打我的人。”当精神科医生解释为什么这不可能时，Rudy 说：“好吧，你看起来很像他。”侦探们很清楚 Rudy 的状况不足以完全被信任，但他们开始考虑他根本不是预定目标这一可能性。鉴于 Bonnie Hood
reputation with various Camp Nelson locals, it was possible that someone with a chip on their shoulder had targeted her. After all, the shooting had taken place in her cabin, and very few people could have known that Rudy would be there. This also raised another possible scenario. Although several townsfolk had suspected the pair were having an affair, there was only one obvious person who might feel compelled to do something about it. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. I've always been a fan of meal kits, but Home Chef really stands out for its effortless
在尼尔森营地当地的名声，很有可能是某个怀恨在心的人针对她。毕竟，枪击事件发生在她的房间里，很少有人会知道 Rudy 会在那里。这也提出了另一种可能的情况。虽然几位镇民怀疑两人有婚外情，但只有一个明显的人可能会觉得有必要对此采取行动。Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。我一直是餐包的粉丝，但 Home Chef 确实因其轻松的
meals that require little prep and cooking time. Their meals are straightforward and easy, which is perfect for someone who's not exactly aiming for a spot on Top Chef. Home Chef delivers fresh ingredients and simple chef-designed recipes right to your door. Whether you prefer classic meal kits with pre-portioned ingredients, speedy 30-minute recipes, oven-ready options or quick microwave meals, Home Chef makes it effortless to enjoy delicious hassle-free meals for the whole family. Home Chef has over 30 options a week and serves a variety of dietary needs.
餐点而脱颖而出，这些餐点几乎不需要准备和烹饪时间。他们的餐点简单易做，非常适合那些并不打算在《顶级大厨》（Top Chef）中占有一席之地的人。Home Chef 将新鲜食材和简单的厨师设计食谱直接送到您家门口。无论您是喜欢带有预先分量食材的经典餐包、快速的 30 分钟食谱、烤箱即食选项还是快速微波炉餐点，Home Chef 都能让全家人轻松享用美味、无忧的餐点。Home Chef 每周有超过 30 种选择，满足各种饮食需求。
They even have a delicious, kid-friendly family menu, which is picky eater approved and takes the stress out of dinnertime. Not only is Home Chef convenient, it's economical too. Their customers save an average of $86 per month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering my listeners 18 free meals plus free dessert for life and of course
他们甚至有美味的、适合儿童的家庭菜单，这些菜单得到了挑食者的认可，消除了晚餐时间的压力。Home Chef 不仅方便，而且经济实惠。他们的客户平均每月在杂货上节省 86 美元。Casefile Presents 系列《贝克斯菲尔德 3》（The Bakersfield 3）的主持人 Olivia LaVoice 非常喜欢 Home Chef 的便利性和所提供食材的高品质。她说，它还向她介绍了她原本不会制作的新食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef 为我的听众提供 18 顿免费餐点，外加终身免费甜点，当然还有
free shipping on your first box. Go to homechef.com slash case file. That's homechef.com slash case file for 18 free meals and free dessert for life. You heard that right. Homecheef.com slash Casefile. Must be an active subscriber to receive free dessert. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Bonnie met her husband Jim Hood when they attended university in the early 1960s.
首单免费送货。请访问 homechef.com/casefile。即 homechef.com/casefile，即可获得 18 顿免费餐点和终身免费甜点。您没听错。Homechef.com/Casefile。必须是活跃订阅者才能获得免费甜点。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供优质内容。Bonnie 在 20 世纪 60 年代初上大学时遇到了她的丈夫 Jim Hood。
They married in 1970 and both took up work in real estate. Jim sold commercial property while Bonnie specialized in helping out-of-state companies relocate to California. The couple were incredibly successful, becoming multimillionaires with a beachside property, a boat and luxury cars. By 1987, Bonnie had reached a point in her life where she was ready to go in a new direction. For as long as she could remember, she'd imagined living full time in a small mountain town. When the Camp Nelson Lodge went up for sale, the hoods saw it as a viable business opportunity. For Bonnie, it was also the fulfillment of her lifelong dream. The only downside was that Bonnie and Jim would have to live apart.
他们于 1970 年结婚，两人都从事房地产工作。Jim 出售商业地产，而 Bonnie 专门帮助外州公司搬迁到加利福尼亚州。这对夫妇非常成功，成为了拥有海滨房产、船只和豪华轿车的千万富翁。到 1987 年，Bonnie 在生活中达到了一个准备向新方向发展的阶段。只要她记得，她就一直想象着全职住在一个小山城里。当尼尔森营地旅馆挂牌出售时，Hood 一家将其视为一个可行的商业机会。对 Bonnie 来说，这也是她终身梦想的实现。唯一的缺点是 Bonnie 和 Jim 将不得不分居两地。
Their children were enrolled in a good school and Jim had business ties in Southern California. Still, Bonnie remained in near constant contact with her husband and children while living in Camp Nelson. She spoke with them on the phone upwards of three times a day and helped her children with their homework almost every night. Twice a month, Bonnie visited Newport Beach to spend a couple of days with her family, and once a month, Jim and the kids spent a weekend at Camp Nelson. When investigators informed Jim Hood about his wife's murder, he appeared genuinely shocked. More so when he was told that Bonnie was having an affair with Rudy Manuel.
他们的孩子在一所好学校就读，而 Jim 在南加州有业务往来。尽管如此，Bonnie 在尼尔森营地生活时，仍与她的丈夫和孩子保持着近乎持续的联系。她每天至少和他们在电话里交谈三次，几乎每天晚上都帮助孩子们做家庭作业。每个月，Bonnie 会去纽波特海滩两次，与家人共度几天，而每个月，Jim 和孩子们会在尼尔森营地度过一个周末。当调查人员通知 Jim Hood 他妻子的谋杀案时，他显得非常震惊。当被告知 Bonnie 与 Rudy Manuel 有婚外情时，他更是如此。
Jim insisted that his marriage was solid and that Bonnie would have never been unfaithful. He knew that Bonnie had a close friendship with Rudy, but refused to accept that the pair were in bed together the night of the shooting. Jim was certain the person responsible was a Camp Nelson local who held a grudge against his wife. He claimed that Bonnie had recently confided in him that she feared for her safety. In addition to investigating illegal logging in the area, she had allegedly stumbled upon a cannabis field while horse riding. Bonnie hadn't notified the police, as she suspected several members of local law
Jim 坚称他的婚姻很稳固，Bonnie 绝不会不忠。他知道 Bonnie 与 Rudy 有着密切的友谊，但拒绝接受两人在枪击当晚睡在一起的事实。Jim 确信负责的人是尼尔森营地的一名当地人，他对他妻子怀恨在心。他声称 Bonnie 最近向他吐露，她担心自己的安全。除了调查该地区的非法伐木外，她在骑马时还偶然发现了一个大麻田。Bonnie 没有通知警方，因为她怀疑当地执法部门的几名成员参与了毒品行动。据 Jim 说，就在她被谋杀前两周，Bonnie 说她发现了一些可能影响加利福尼亚州重大政治选举结果的信息。Jim 说，Bonnie 一直在为社区中几名她怀疑参与非法活动的成员保留档案。她在最近一次访问时向他展示过，他知道她把它放在一个锁着的档案柜里。警方允许 Jim 进入 Bonnie 的小屋收集档案。他走到她的
enforcement were involved in the drug operation. According to Jim, just two weeks before she was murdered, Bonnie said she'd uncovered information that could potentially impact the outcome of a major political election in California. Jim said that Bonnie had been keeping files on several members of the community who she suspected were involved in illegal activity. She had shown it to him during a recent visit and he knew she kept it in a locked filing cabinet. Police permitted Jim to enter Bonnie's cabin to collect the dossier. He went to her
档案柜前，却发现它没锁，档案也不见了。随着几周过去，Rudy Manuel 继续稳步康复。出院后，他直接与 Jim Hood 对质，询问他是否为了嫉妒报复他们的婚外情而雇佣了杀手来杀他和 Bonnie。Rudy 声称 Jim 泪流满面，问他怎么能想出这种事。调查人员保持开放的态度。他们收集了旅馆里在杀戮之夜积累的所有空啤酒瓶，并对它们进行了指纹检测。如果那个在酒吧喝酒的难以捉摸的陌生人确实是凶手，
filing cabinet only to find it was unlocked and the file was missing. As the weeks passed, Rudy Manuel continued to make a steady recovery. After being released from hospital, he straight up confronted Jim Hood, asking if he'd hired a hitman to kill him and Bonnie in jealous retaliation of their affair. Rudy claimed that Jim broke down in tears, asking how he could even think such a thing. Investigators remained open-minded. They had collected all of the empty beer bottles from the lodge that had accumulated on the night of the killing and had them tested for fingerprints. If the elusive stranger seen drinking at the bar was indeed the killer,
很有可能他有犯罪记录。结果显示，几个指纹属于一名叫 Bruce Beecham 的已知重罪犯。他的入案照片看起来和 Rudy 对枪手的描述一模一样。Rudy 被展示了另一组照片，这次混入了 Bruce Beecham 的照片。Rudy 自信地认定 Bruce 就是枪手。旅馆的员工也一致同意 Bruce 就是他们那天晚上在酒吧看到喝酒的陌生人。31 岁的 Bruce Beecham 是一个骑着摩托车的流浪汉，在美国西部各地游荡。他有关于销售大麻、向儿童挥舞枪支、袭击前妻和酒后驾车的定罪记录。
there was a strong possibility that he had a criminal record. The results revealed that several fingerprints belonged to a known felon named Bruce Beecham. His mugshot looked just like Rudy's description of the gunman. Rudy was shown another photo line-up, this time with an image of Bruce Beecham in the mix. Rudy confidently identified Bruce as the shooter. Employees at the lodge also unanimously agreed that Bruce was the stranger they'd seen drinking at the bar that night. 31-year-old Bruce Beecham was a drifter with biker tyres who moved across the American West. He had convictions pertaining to selling cannabis, brandishing a gun towards children, assaulting his ex-wife, and driving under the influence.
他最近定居在洛杉矶以东一小时车程的一个城市，在那里他为一个名为 Mission Plaza 的购物中心担任维修领班。当警察接近时，Bruce 承认他最近去过尼尔森营地。他说他在枪击事件发生前的那个周末去了那里，在那里他遇到了一个女人，两人同意下周在那里再次见面。他在 8 月 18 日星期六的那个周末回来，却发现那个女人放了他鸽子。Bruce 说他整晚都在镇上仅有的两家酒吧之间穿梭寻找她，同时受到酒精和甲基苯丙胺的影响。在 Bruce 因为对一个女人发表侮辱性言论而被一家酒吧赶出来后，他一直待在旅馆直到打烊。他声称在离开酒吧后，他开车 232 英里向南前往朋友家
He'd recently settled in a city an hour east of Los Angeles where he worked as a maintenance foreman for a shopping complex called Mission Plaza. When approached by police, Bruce admitted he'd recently been to Camp Nelson. He said he'd gone there on the weekend before the shooting where he'd met a woman and the two had agreed to meet there again the following week. He returned on the weekend of Saturday August 18, only to find that the woman had stood him up. Bruce said he spent the night hopping between the only two bars in town on the lookout for her, while under the influence of alcohol and methamphetamines. After Bruce was kicked out of one bar for making an insulting remark to a woman, he remained at the lodge until closing time. He claimed that upon leaving the bar, he drove 232 miles south to a friend's house
在丰塔纳市，大约凌晨 6 点到达那里。Bruce 的朋友证实了他的说法，称他们花了一天时间一起逛庭院拍卖。时间点很重要。从尼尔森营地到丰塔纳的车程至少需要四个小时。Bonnie Hood 和 Rudy Manuel 在凌晨 3 点多一点被枪杀。调查人员复制了 Bruce 的行程，看看他们是否能在三小时内到达丰塔纳。他们尽可能快地开车，但最终还是用了三小时 45 分钟才到达那里。要么是 Bruce 的不在场证明错了，要么他不是凶手。还有别的事。在与调查人员交谈时，Bruce Beecham 透露了一个重要的信息。他很惊讶他们花了这么长时间才来找他谈论
in the city of Fontana, arriving there at around 6am. Bruce's friend corroborated his story, stating that they spent the day visiting yard sales together. The timing was significant. The drive from Camp Nelson to Fontana took at least four hours. Bonnie Hood and Rudy Manuel were shot a little after 3am. Investigators replicated Bruce's journey to see if they could reach Fontana in under three hours. They drove as fast as they could and yet only managed to get there in three hours and 45 minutes. Either Bruce's alibi was wrong or he was not the killer. There was something else. When speaking with investigators, Bruce Beecham divulged a significant piece of information. He was surprised it had taken them so long to come and speak with him in relation to
犯罪。毕竟，是他的雇主首先给了他去尼尔森营地的想法。Jim Hood。Jim Hood 是 Bruce Beecham 工作的 Mission Plaza 购物中心的共同所有者。Bruce 声称 Jim 总是和他的员工谈论尼尔森营地，鼓励他们去那里，在旅馆里玩得开心。随着这一揭露在他们的主要嫌疑人和 Bonnie Hood 的丈夫之间形成了意想不到的联系，警方搜查了 Bruce 的家。他们发现了一双网球鞋，其品牌和尺码与枪击当晚在 Bonnie 小屋外面发现的鞋印相同。Bruce Beecham 被捕并被控谋杀、谋杀未遂、抢劫未遂、入室盗窃和使用致命武器袭击。调查人员感觉到他们只揭开了
the crime. After all, it was his employer who had given him the idea to go to Camp Nelson in the first place. Jim Hood. Jim Hood co-owned the Mission Plaza shopping complex where Bruce Beecham worked. Bruce claimed that Jim always talked to his employees about Camp Nelson, encouraging them to go up there and have a good time at the lodge. With this revelation forming an unexpected connection between their prime suspect and Bonnie Hood's husband, police searched Bruce's home. They uncovered a pair of tennis shoes that were the same brand and size as the shoe prints found outside Bonnie's cabin on the night of the shooting. Bruce Beecham was arrested and charged with murder, attempted murder, attempted robbery, burglary and assault with a deadly weapon. Investigators sensed they had only uncovered
更大叙事的一部分，检察官在预审听证会上宣布：“极有可能存在犯罪阴谋。可能还有其他嫌疑人。”其他嫌疑人的观点涉及调查人员已经知道的一个人。当 Jim Hood 被告知 Bruce Beecham 被捕时，他显得很震惊。他声称他不认为 Bruce 见过 Bonnie，也不是那种会做这种事的人。尽管如此，Jim Hood 雇佣 Bruce Beecham 谋杀他的
part of a larger narrative with the prosecutor announcing at a pre-trial hearing. There is a very, very good possibility there is a criminal conspiracy. There may be other suspects. The other suspects point pertained to an individual already known to investigators. When Jim Hood was informed of Bruce Beecham's arrest, he appeared shocked. He claimed that he didn't think Bruce had ever met Bonnie or was the type of person to do such a thing. Despite this, it remained possible that Jim Hood had hired Bruce Beecham to murder his
妻子仍然是有可能的。尽管 Jim 否认知道他妻子与 Rudy Manuel 的婚外情，但这种情况是谋杀的永恒动机。证据未能澄清此事。虽然 Bonnie 有一份 75 万美元的人寿保险，但对 Jim Hood 拥有的枪支进行的弹道测试证实，其中没有一把被用于犯罪。也没有纸质记录表明 Bruce Beecham 最近收到了任何大笔款项。如果真相掌握在任何一个人手中，他们都没有说出来。尽管面临潜在的死刑，Bruce Beecham 拒绝牵连 Jim Hood，并继续否认与犯罪有任何关系。调查人员有他们自己的怀疑。毕竟，如果 Bruce 是被雇来杀 Bonnie 的，
wife. Despite Jim denying any knowledge of his wife's affair with Rudy Manuel, the situation was a timeless motive for murder. Evidence failed to clarify the matter. While Bonnie had a $750,000 life insurance policy, ballistics on guns Jim Hood owned confirmed none of them had been used in the crime. There were no paper trails indicating that Bruce Beecham had recently received any large sums of money either. If the truth was held by either man, they weren't talking. Despite facing a potential death sentence, Bruce Beecham refused to implicate Jim Hood and continued to deny having anything to do with the crime. Investigators harboured their own doubts. After all, if Bruce had been hired to kill Bonnie,
为什么他会连续两个周末访问尼尔森营地，光顾当地酒吧，并与各种目击者互动？在没有出现相反证据的情况下，Jim Hood 被正式排除在嫌疑人之外。Bruce Beecham 于 1991 年 2 月受审，即 Bonnie Hood 被杀六个月后。到那时，调查人员已经确定了犯罪动机是经济驱动的理论，因为 Bruce 无意中听到了 Bonnie 谈论从酒吧收集的大量小费。鉴于 Bruce 知道 Bonnie 嫁给了 Jim，他很可能认为她那天晚上会独自在小屋里，因此是一个容易抢劫的目标。在醉酒状态下，Bruce 前往 Bonnie 的小屋，却发现有另一个男人在场。
why would he visit Camp Nelson over two consecutive weekends, attend the local bars, and interact with various witnesses? Without any evidence emerging to the contrary, Jim Hood was officially ruled out as a suspect. Bruce Beecham went to trial in February 1991, six months after Bonnie Hood was killed. By this point, investigators had settled on the theory that the crime was financially motivated after Bruce had overheard Bonnie talk about the large amount of tips collected from the bar. Given that Bruce knew Bonnie was married to Jim, he most likely assumed she would be alone in her cabin that night, thus an easy target to rob. Heavily intoxicated, Bruce headed to Bonnie's cabin only to discover another man was present.
Bruce 的计划很快就从那里瓦解了。他在惊慌中逃离现场之前枪杀了 Bonnie 和 Rudy Manuel。检方对 Bruce 给警察的凌晨 6 点的不在场证明表示怀疑，称其不可靠。为他作证的朋友要么是在撒谎，要么是弄错了。用检方的话说，这“……是一个导致谋杀和谋杀未遂的简单抢劫案。”检方的明星证人是 Rudy Manuel。当在证人席上被问及是谁开枪打他时，Rudy 指着 Bruce Beecham 并宣布：“毫无疑问，他就是那个人。”但当 Rudy 开始作证时，他的故事包含了许多与他最初告诉警察的故事明显不同的细节。在宣誓后，Rudy 否认曾与
to discover another man was present. Bruce's plan quickly unraveled from there. He shot Bonnie and Rudy Manuel before fleeing the scene in a panic. The prosecution expressed doubts about the 6am alibi Bruce had given police saying that it was unreliable. His friend that had vouched for him was either lying or mistaken. In the prosecution's words, it was, "...a simple case of robbery that led to murder and attempted murder." The prosecution's star witness was Rudy Manuel. When asked on the stand about who shot him, Rudy pointed to Bruce Beecham and announced, there's no doubt he's the one. But as soon as Rudy started giving his testimony, his story contained a number of markedly different details from the story he'd originally given police. Under oath, Rudy denied ever having an affair
Bonnie Hood 有过婚外情。他声称他那天晚上去她的小屋只是为了聊天，并且一直坐在她的床边开着灯聊天，这时 Bruce Beecham 突然冲进门来。Rudy 回忆说：“他告诉我我是一个死混蛋，而且态度非常粗鲁。他说，‘跪下，脸朝地。’我不想这样做，因为我知道他会开枪打我。”Rudy 声称他试图把枪从 Bruce 手中踢掉，就在那时他的头部中弹了。
with Bonnie Hood. He claimed he had visited her cabin that night just to talk and had been sitting on the edge of her bed chatting with the lights on when Bruce Beecham suddenly burst through the door. Rudy recalled, He told me I was a dead motherfucker and he was very rude about it. He said, get on your knees and face the floor. I didn't want to do it because I knew he would shoot me." Rudy claimed he tried to kick the gun out of Bruce's hand and that's when he was shot in the head.
他解释说：“然后发生了一场搏斗，又开了两枪。我想 Bonnie 从床上站了起来，这时被告与她发生了争执。这个男人跳到了床上。我相信她在为生命而战，又开了两枪。”这是 Rudy 第一次提到发生了搏斗。检察官将 Rudy 不同的回忆归因于他严重的头部创伤。然而，辩方辩称他是在编造新的细节以符合物证。在审判期间，有证据表明 Bonnie 的指甲表明她曾与袭击者搏斗过。
He explained, then there was a struggle and two more shots. I think Bonnie stood up on the bed and at this time, the defendant fought with her. This man right here jumped on the bed. I believe she was fighting for her life and there were two more shots. This was the first time Rudy had ever mentioned a struggle taking place. Prosecutors attributed Rudy's differing recollections to his severe head trauma. The defence, however, contended that he was making up new details to fit the physical evidence. During the trial, it had been revealed that Bonnie's fingernails indicated she had struggled with her attacker.
他解释说，随后发生了挣扎，又开了两枪。我想邦妮当时从床上站了起来，这时被告与她发生了搏斗。就是这个男人跳到了床上。我相信她当时在为生命而战，随后又响了两声枪。这是鲁迪第一次提到发生了挣扎。检察官将鲁迪记忆的前后不一归因于他严重的头部创伤。然而，辩方则认为他是在编造新的细节以符合物证。在审判过程中，有证据显示邦妮的指甲表明她曾与袭击者发生过搏斗。
The defense believed that Rudy was falsifying his story to suit this finding as well as other key evidence, including the fact that semen had been found inside Bonnie that couldn't be linked to anyone in particular. From the defences perspective, the semen indicated that Rudy wasn't being entirely truthful about what he and Bonnie did that night. Testimony provided by the county coroner rebuffed Rudy's story further. The coroner held the opinion that Bonnie was killed elsewhere and then moved to the bed. He highlighted the blood spatter from the crime scene, specifically the neat trickle of blood that ran from Bonnie's ear, down her chin and across her neck. The coroner claimed this didn't coincide with someone being shot while lying in bed, explaining, "...when a person gets shot, blood splatters all about. This is the tidiest homicide
辩方认为，鲁迪编造故事是为了迎合这一发现以及其他关键证据，包括在邦妮体内发现的精液无法与任何特定的人联系起来这一事实。从辩方的角度来看，精液表明鲁迪对自己和邦妮那天晚上所做的事情并没有完全说实话。县验尸官提供的证词进一步反驳了鲁迪的说法。验尸官认为邦妮是在别处被杀，然后被移到床上的。他强调了犯罪现场的血迹，特别是从邦妮耳边流下，经过下巴并横过脖子的那道整齐的血迹。验尸官声称这与某人在床上被枪杀的情况不符，并解释说：“……当一个人被枪杀时，血会四处飞溅。这是我担任验尸官12年来见过的最整洁的凶杀
scene I've seen in 12 years as a coroner. This is too tidy, not what we see in violent death. This is too tidy, not what we see in violent death. It's not consistent with the struggle Rudy Manuel said occurred. The defence told the jury, the only conclusion you can draw is that Rudy Manuel is a liar. Something happened in that cabin that night he's not telling us about. Something happened in that cabin that night he's not telling us about. After deliberations, the jury produced the first ever acquittal in a murder trial in the county's history. One of the jurors later told a reporter, we never ever, any of us, thought Bruce Beecham was guilty. There was not enough evidence to convict him. As for Rudy Manuel's testimony, Jura's opinions were overwhelmingly negative.
现场。这太整洁了，不是我们在暴力死亡中看到的。这太整洁了，不是我们在暴力死亡中看到的。这与鲁迪·曼努埃尔所说的挣扎情况不符。辩方告诉陪审团，你们唯一能得出的结论就是鲁迪·曼努埃尔是个骗子。那天晚上在那间小屋里发生了一些他没有告诉我们的事情。那天晚上在那间小屋里发生了一些他没有告诉我们的事情。经过审议，陪审团做出了该县历史上谋杀案审判中的首次无罪判决。其中一名陪审员后来告诉记者，我们从来没有，我们所有人，认为布鲁斯·比彻姆有罪。没有足够的证据给他定罪。至于鲁迪·曼努埃尔的证词，陪审员的意见绝大多数是负面的。
While some considered his memory unreliable, others believed he was deliberately lying. Upon hearing the verdict, Bruce Beecham turned to his lawyer and said, thank God, thank God they believed us. Jim Hood remained staunch, telling reporters he would never give up looking for his wife's murderer. wife's murderer. I will be pursuing it, he remarked, before adding somewhat ominously. But I don't want to say how. Upon his release from custody, Bruce Beecham started putting his life back together. He quickly married a woman named Sharon Spray, a convicted criminal whom Bruce became pampers with while in jail. In an interview with the Porterville Recorder, in the months after his acquittal,
虽然有些人认为他的记忆不可靠，但另一些人认为他在故意撒谎。听到判决后，布鲁斯·比彻姆转向他的律师说，感谢上帝，感谢上帝他们相信了我们。吉姆·胡德立场坚定，告诉记者他永远不会放弃寻找杀害他妻子的凶手。妻子的凶手。我会继续追查的，他评论道，随后又有些不祥地补充道。但我不想说怎么追查。在获释后，布鲁斯·比彻姆开始重新整理他的生活。他很快娶了一位名叫莎伦·斯普雷的女子，这是一名曾被定罪的罪犯，布鲁斯在监狱里时曾与她调情。在获释后的几个月里，在接受《波特维尔记录报》采访时，
Bruce claimed he had cleaned up his life and was completely sober. In reality, he and his wife had become frequent heroin users. and his wife had become frequent heroin users. The now-unemployed Bruce admitted that he'd considered asking Jim Hood for his old job back, but didn't think that would go down well. Even though Bruce wasn't working, his friends and family noticed that he was rarely short on cash and was often seen counting out stacks of $100 bills. Even his wife had noticed this inexplicable flow of money. One day when they were low on funds, Bruce told Sharon that he was going to pay someone a visit.
布鲁斯声称他已经改过自新，完全戒酒了。实际上，他和他的妻子已经成了频繁的海洛因使用者。和他的妻子已经成了频繁的海洛因使用者。现在失业的布鲁斯承认，他曾考虑过请求吉姆·胡德让他回原来的工作岗位，但觉得这不会顺利。尽管布鲁斯没有工作，但他的朋友和家人注意到他很少缺钱，而且经常被看到在数着一叠叠100美元的钞票。甚至他的妻子也注意到了这笔莫名其妙的钱财来源。有一天，当他们资金短缺时，布鲁斯告诉莎伦他要去拜访某个人。
45 minutes later, he returned with an envelope containing $5,000 cash. In January 1992, a year and a half after Bonnie Hood's murder, Bruce Beecham recruited his brother-in-law, Gary Spray, to carry out a break-in. He told Gary his intended target was Jim Hood. Gary was apprehensive, but Bruce assured him they had nothing to fear. He said that even if they did get caught, Jim Hood would never prosecute them. According to Bruce, he had something over Jim that ensured his cooperation. The two men broke into Jim's office at the Mission Plaza shopping centre and stole $18,000
45分钟后，他带着一个装有5000美元现金的信封回来了。1992年1月，在邦妮·胡德被谋杀一年半后，布鲁斯·比彻姆招募了他的妹夫加里·斯普雷去实施入室盗窃。他告诉加里他的目标是吉姆·胡德。加里很担心，但布鲁斯向他保证他们没什么好怕的。他说，即使他们被抓住了，吉姆·胡德也永远不会起诉他们。据布鲁斯说，他手里有吉姆的把柄，确保了他的配合。这两个人闯入了吉姆在使命广场购物中心的办公室，偷走了价值18000美元的
worth of construction equipment, which they then hid inside a storage facility. When the items were discovered to be missing, an advertisement was placed in the local newspaper offering $3,000 for the safe return of the stolen goods. Gary Spray called the number on the advertisement and spoke with the Jim Hood's business partner Pat, offering to return the stolen equipment for $6,000. Pat agreed and it was decided that the exchange would take place at the storage locker where the items were being kept. When Gary arrived at the locker, police were already waiting.
建筑设备，然后把它们藏在了一个仓储设施里。当发现物品丢失时，当地报纸上刊登了一则广告，悬赏3000美元以安全归还被盗物品。加里·斯普雷拨打了广告上的电话，与吉姆·胡德的商业伙伴帕特进行了交谈，提出以6000美元的价格归还被盗设备。帕特同意了，并决定在存放物品的储物柜进行交换。当加里到达储物柜时，警察已经在那里等候了。
As he was placed under arrest, he yelled at Pat, "'You messed up. Some things from the past will come out. After this, Jim Hood began receiving phone calls from Bruce Beecham demanding that the charges against his brother-in-law be dropped. On one occasion, Bruce left a message on Jim's answering machine that said, "'If you don't start dealing with me properly, I'm going to sink you.'" Despite these efforts, the charges against the Gary Spray remained. He pleaded guilty and was sent to jail for two months.
当他被逮捕时，他对着帕特大喊：“你搞砸了。过去的一些事情会曝光的。”此后，吉姆·胡德开始接到布鲁斯·比彻姆的电话，要求撤销对他妹夫的指控。有一次，布鲁斯在吉姆的电话答录机上留言说：“如果你不开始妥善处理这件事，我就要让你完蛋。”尽管有这些努力，针对加里·斯普雷的指控仍然存在。他认罪并被判入狱两个月。
But the saga wasn't over. Bruce Beecham continued his threatening calls against the Jim Hood, leading to Jim becoming so paranoid that he began carrying a loaded handgun with him at all times. He slept with it next to his bed, while also keeping a loaded 9mm Glock pistol in the drawer of his office desk. Monday, March 2, 1992 marked almost a year since Bruce Beecham's acquittal for the murder of Bonnie Hood. Bruce asked a friend to drive him to Jim Hood's office at Mission Plaza. The two men had spoken on the phone earlier that morning and Jim had invited Bruce to his office so they could sort things out once and for all. When Bruce entered the building, he moved past
但这场传奇并没有结束。布鲁斯·比彻姆继续对吉姆·胡德进行威胁电话，导致吉姆变得非常多疑，以至于他开始随身携带一把装满子弹的手枪。他睡觉时把它放在床边，同时还在办公桌的抽屉里放了一把装满子弹的9毫米格洛克手枪。1992年3月2日，星期一，标志着布鲁斯·比彻姆因谋杀邦妮·胡德被判无罪已近一年。布鲁斯请一位朋友开车送他去使命广场的吉姆·胡德办公室。两人那天早上早些时候通过电话，吉姆邀请布鲁斯去他的办公室，这样他们就可以一劳永逸地解决问题。当布鲁斯进入大楼时，他越过了
Jim's secretary and into the private office space where Jim was waiting. The door was closed behind them. Seconds later, two gunshots rang out from the office in quick succession, followed by a brief pause, then five more shots. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Police arrived at Mission Plaza to find Bruce Beecham dead on the floor of Jim Hood's office. He had been shot seven times. His right hand was clutching an unregistered blue steel.357 Magnum revolver. Jim Hood was immediately taken in for questioning, and over the next 12
吉姆的秘书，进入了吉姆正在等待的私人办公空间。门在他们身后关上了。几秒钟后，办公室里传出两声急促的枪响，随后短暂的停顿，接着又是五声枪响。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。警察到达使命广场，发现布鲁斯·比彻姆死在吉姆·胡德办公室的地板上。他被击中了七次。他的右手紧紧抓着一把未登记的蓝钢.357马格南左轮手枪。吉姆·胡德立即被带去接受审讯，在接下来的12
hours he explained the deadly confrontation in detail. He said that over the past several weeks, Bruce had been making increasingly threatening phone calls to him. Jim began actively avoiding Bruce's calls, but that morning, Bruce called the office threatening to bury Jim. Fed up, Jim finally agreed to meet in person to sort their conflict diplomatically. He believed the conversation would be about the theft of the construction equipment and the recent incarceration of Bruce's brother-in-law, Gary Spray. Jim suspected trouble the moment Bruce entered his office. As Jim sat behind his desk, he noticed Bruce's hands were shaking, particularly the left one.
个小时里，他详细解释了这场致命的对抗。他说，在过去的几周里，布鲁斯一直在给他打越来越多的威胁电话。吉姆开始积极回避布鲁斯的电话，但那天早上，布鲁斯打电话到办公室威胁要埋了吉姆。忍无可忍的吉姆终于同意亲自见面，以外交方式解决他们的冲突。他认为谈话内容将是关于建筑设备的盗窃以及布鲁斯的妹夫加里·斯普雷最近的入狱。吉姆在布鲁斯进入他办公室的那一刻就预感到了麻烦。当吉姆坐在办公桌后时，他注意到布鲁斯的手在颤抖，尤其是左手。
His eyes were also bulging as if he were about to lash out. Bruce suddenly reached behind his back and pulled out a revolver. But before Bruce could fire a shot, Jim reached into his desk drawer, drew his own pistol, and started shooting. The first two shots struck Bruce in the chest and he immediately fell to the floor. Jim stood up and walked over to him. He noticed that Bruce's head and the arm he was holding the gun in were moving suspiciously. He proceeded to shoot Bruce several more times to ensure he was dead. If Jim's word was true, the situation was clearly self-defence. But investigators could tell from the get-go that not everything was as it seemed.
他的眼睛也瞪得很大，好像要发作一样。布鲁斯突然伸手到背后，掏出一把左轮手枪。但在布鲁斯开枪之前，吉姆伸手拉开办公桌抽屉，掏出自己的手枪，开始射击。前两枪击中了布鲁斯的胸部，他立即倒在地上。吉姆站起来走到他身边。他注意到布鲁斯的头部和他握枪的手臂在可疑地移动。他继续又向布鲁斯开了几枪，以确保他已经死了。如果吉姆的话是真的，这种情况显然是正当防卫。但调查人员从一开始就能看出，事情并非看起来那样。
Firstly, the friend who dropped Bruce Beecham at Mission Plaza said it didn't appear that Bruce had been armed with a gun. Bruce had told his friend that he suspected Jim had set a trap for him and he expected to be arrested when he arrived at Jim's office. He was carrying a knife which he left in the car because he didn't want to be armed when the confrontation occurred. As far as Bruce's friend was concerned, Bruce exited the car with nothing more than the clothes on his back. While Jim Hood asserted that Bruce had been noticeably on edge and irritated when he arrived at the office, Jim's secretary described Bruce's demeanour as perfectly happy, even jovial.
首先，那位送布鲁斯·比彻姆到使命广场的朋友说，布鲁斯看起来并没有携带枪支。布鲁斯曾告诉他的朋友，他怀疑吉姆给他设了陷阱，并预计他到达吉姆办公室时会被逮捕。他带着一把刀，但他把它留在了车里，因为他不想在发生对抗时携带武器。就布鲁斯的朋友而言，布鲁斯下车时身上除了衣服什么都没有。虽然吉姆·胡德断言布鲁斯到达办公室时明显处于紧张和烦躁状态，但吉姆的秘书形容布鲁斯的举止非常愉快，甚至有些风趣。
The crime scene itself also didn't align with Jim Hood's story. Firstly, the lead investigator's attention was immediately drawn to the way Bruce Beecham was still grasping his firearm. In all his years as a homicide detective, the investigator had never seen a murder victim still holding onto their gun after being shot and falling to the ground, especially on a concrete floor. Secondly, the revolver was in Bruce's right hand, yet Bruce was left handed. A smear between two pools of blood indicated that Bruce's body had been moved after his death. There was also blood on Bruce's right hand as well as on the floor underneath it, yet
犯罪现场本身也不符合吉姆·胡德的说法。首先，首席调查员的注意力立即被布鲁斯·比彻姆仍然抓着他的枪的方式所吸引。在他担任凶杀案侦探的所有岁月里，调查员从未见过谋杀受害者在被枪杀并倒地后仍然握着他们的枪，尤其是在水泥地板上。其次，左轮手枪在布鲁斯的右手，但布鲁斯是左撇子。两滩血迹之间的一道涂抹痕迹表明布鲁斯的尸体在他死后被移动过。布鲁斯的右手以及它下面的地板上也有血迹，然而
the gun itself was clean. If Bruce was holding the gun at the time of the shooting. This was an impossible feat. It was clear to investigators that the gun had been placed in Bruce's hand after he'd been shot. Gunpowder residue recovered on the palms of Bruce's hands showed he had his hands up in a defensive posture when Jim Hood pulled the trigger. With the Jims story falling apart, he was placed under arrest for the murder of Bruce Beecham. Despite Jim's insistence that Bruce's death was in no way connected to Bonnie's murder,
枪本身却是干净的。如果布鲁斯在枪击时握着枪，这是一个不可能完成的任务。调查人员很清楚，枪是在布鲁斯被枪杀后才被放入他手中的。在布鲁斯手掌上发现的火药残留物显示，当吉姆·胡德扣动扳机时，他正举着双手处于防御姿势。随着吉姆的故事破灭，他因谋杀布鲁斯·比彻姆而被捕。尽管吉姆坚称布鲁斯的死与邦妮的谋杀案毫无关联，
the complex case caused a media frenzy. Speculation ran wild that Jim had murdered Bruce as payback for killing his wife. Shooting survivor Rudy Manuel maintained that Bruce Beecham was the man responsible for attacking him and Bonnie. Speaking with the Porterville Recorder, Rudy said, "...Bruce Beecham died the same way as Bonnie, cold-heartedly and point blank. Our family can finally relax and not be fearful of strange cars in the driveway. But investigators weren't so sure that Bruce's murder was motivated by revenge. They had previously considered the possibility that Jim Hood had hired Bruce to kill Bonnie, and he'd only been cleared due to a lack of evidence. At the time, police had opted to pursue Bruce first, thinking his would be an
这起复杂的案件引起了媒体的狂热。人们纷纷猜测吉姆谋杀布鲁斯是为了报复他杀害了自己的妻子。枪击幸存者鲁迪·曼努埃尔坚持认为布鲁斯·比彻姆是袭击他和邦妮的凶手。在接受《波特维尔记录报》采访时，鲁迪说：“……布鲁斯·比彻姆死得和邦妮一样，冷酷无情，近距离射击。我们的家人终于可以放松了，不用再害怕车道上的陌生车辆了。”但调查人员并不确定布鲁斯的谋杀案是否出于报复动机。他们之前曾考虑过吉姆·胡德雇佣布鲁斯杀害邦妮的可能性，而他只是因为缺乏证据才被洗清嫌疑。当时，警方选择先追查布鲁斯，认为他的案子会更容易
easier conviction to secure. They'd been convinced that Bruce would be found guilty and he would then confess to Jim's involvement in exchange for a more lenient sentence. One officer admitted, "...we were biting at the bit to find Bruce Beecham guilty so we could get on with the case. And we were prepared to do that. However, when Bruce was unexpectedly acquitted, it destroyed the possibility of Jim Hood facing any charges. If he was indeed involved, then all those responsible for Bonnie Hood's death had seemingly gotten away with murder. Two days after Bruce Beecham's death, his widow Sharon Spray told investigators that
获得定罪。他们确信布鲁斯会被判有罪，然后他会为了换取更轻的刑罚而供出吉姆的参与。一名警官承认：“……我们急于给布鲁斯·比彻姆定罪，这样我们就可以继续处理这个案子。我们准备那样做。然而，当布鲁斯意外被判无罪时，这摧毁了吉姆·胡德面临任何指控的可能性。如果他确实参与其中，那么所有对邦妮·胡德之死负责的人似乎都逃脱了谋杀罪的惩罚。”在布鲁斯·比彻姆死后两天，他的遗孀莎伦·斯普雷告诉调查人员，
in the months after Bruce was acquitted for Bonnie's murder, she found an envelope hidden underneath the headboard of her bed. It contained $10,000 in cash. Sharon confronted Bruce, who said the money was linked to Bonnie's murder. Sharon had always believed in Bruce's innocence and was therefore stunned when she asked Bruce if he had killed Bonnie and he said yes. According to Sharon, Bruce claimed that Jim Hood had paid him $50,000 to murder Bonnie. Following his acquittal, Bruce faced mortgage stress and was in the throes of a heroin addiction. By 1992, he had blown through the bulk of Jim's money, but realised he was in a unique position.
在布鲁斯因谋杀邦妮被判无罪后的几个月里，她在床头板下发现了一个信封。里面装有10000美元现金。莎伦质问布鲁斯，布鲁斯说这笔钱与邦妮的谋杀案有关。莎伦一直相信布鲁斯的清白，因此当她问布鲁斯是否杀害了邦妮而他说“是”时，她感到震惊。据莎伦说，布鲁斯声称吉姆·胡德付给他50000美元去谋杀邦妮。在被判无罪后，布鲁斯面临抵押贷款压力，并处于海洛因成瘾的痛苦中。到1992年，他已经挥霍掉了吉姆给他的大部分钱，但他意识到自己处于一个独特的境地。
Because of double jeopardy laws, he could never be tried for Bonnie's murder again, even if he confessed. He even sought the advice of a paralegal who confirmed this to be the case. Emboldened by this knowledge and motivated to profit on his story, Bruce consulted a freelance author about writing a tell-all book about what really happened in Camp Nelson. He knew that such a revelation would not only ruin Jim Hood's business and reputation, but likely result in Jim being arrested for Bonnie's murder. Bruce used this as leverage to squeeze more money out of Jim. He bombarded him with threatening calls, trying to extort and blackmail him. He demanded that Jim
由于双重危险法律，他永远不能再因邦妮的谋杀案受审，即使他供认了。他甚至寻求了一位律师助理的建议，对方证实了这一点。受到这一知识的鼓舞，并出于从他的故事中获利的动机，布鲁斯咨询了一位自由撰稿人，打算写一本关于坎普尼尔森到底发生了什么的揭秘书。他知道，这样的揭露不仅会毁掉吉姆·胡德的事业和声誉，还很可能导致吉姆因谋杀邦妮而被捕。布鲁斯利用这一点作为筹码，从吉姆那里榨取更多的钱。他用威胁电话轰炸他，试图勒索和敲诈他。他要求吉姆
make a wire transfer to his bank account, but Jim was reluctant to leave a paper trail. Instead, Jim told Bruce to meet him at his office to settle the matter there. In the lead up to the meeting, Bruce didn't know what to expect. He told his wife Sharon, Jim either wants to kill me, set me up to get arrested, or pay me off. wants to kill me, set me up to get arrested, or pay me off." Sharon's story was corroborated by her brother, Gary Spray, who was involved in Bruce's campaign against Jim Hood. Gary added that Jim had initially agreed to pay Bruce $250,000. The $50,000 Bruce had already received was the first of what was supposed to be a series
向他的银行账户进行电汇，但吉姆不愿留下纸质记录。相反，吉姆告诉布鲁斯去他的办公室见面，在那里解决问题。在会议之前，布鲁斯不知道会发生什么。他告诉他的妻子莎伦：“吉姆要么想杀了我，要么设局让我被捕，要么付钱给我。”莎伦的故事得到了她哥哥加里·斯普雷的证实，他参与了布鲁斯针对吉姆·胡德的行动。加里补充说，吉姆最初同意支付布鲁斯250000美元。布鲁斯已经收到的50000美元是本应分期支付的系列款项中的第一笔，
of installments paid out by Jim every six months. It was when Jim failed to pay Bruce as promised that Bruce and Gary hatched their plan to steal the construction equipment from him. Investigators knew Sharon and Gary Spray's testimonies amounted to little more than hearsay and might not even be admissible in court. Given their criminal history and drug use, a jury would also be less inclined to consider them credible witnesses. witnesses. Instead, they worked to uncover more evidence of their claims, starting with a solid motive.
吉姆每六个月支付一次。正是因为吉姆没有像承诺的那样支付布鲁斯钱，布鲁斯和加里才策划了从他那里偷走建筑设备的计划。调查人员知道莎伦和加里·斯普雷的证词充其量只是传闻，甚至可能在法庭上不被采纳。考虑到他们的犯罪记录和吸毒史，陪审团也不太可能认为他们是可信的证人。相反，他们致力于挖掘更多证据来支持他们的主张，从一个坚实的动机开始。
The obvious one was Bonnie's alleged affair with Rudy Manuel. Residents of Camp Nelson referred to the relationship as the worst kept secret in town, but investigators could only find one witness who claimed to have actually seen the pair acting intimately. A bartender from the lodge said he'd seen Bonnie and Rudy kiss on one occasion, hardly enough evidence to prove a long-standing sexual affair. While Rudy had initially admitted to the affair, he'd changed his story at Bruce's trial and denied it ever happened. If he changed his story again, it would mean admitting that he'd committed perjury in a murder trial. Although the truth about the affair remained up for debate, there was evidence that Jim
显而易见的一个动机是邦妮与鲁迪·曼努埃尔所谓的婚外情。坎普尼尔森的居民称这段关系为镇上最公开的秘密，但调查人员只能找到一名证人，声称亲眼见过两人表现亲密。旅馆的一名酒保说，他曾有一次看到邦妮和鲁迪接吻，这很难作为证明长期性关系的证据。虽然鲁迪最初承认了这段婚外情，但在布鲁斯的审判中他改变了说法，否认它曾经发生过。如果他再次改变说法，那就意味着承认他在谋杀案审判中作了伪证。尽管关于这段婚外情的真相仍有争议，但有证据表明吉姆
and Bonnie's marriage was on the rocks. Several people close to Bonnie claimed that she'd talked openly about divorcing Jim in the days prior to her murder. According to Bonnie's bookkeeper, Bonnie had scheduled an appointment with a divorce attorney on Monday August 20, 1990, the night before she was killed. Financial gain was another potential motive. Jim had always maintained that the lodge was breaking even financially, but a review of his tax records showed that the business had lost $550,000 between 1989 and 1990. Jim was also found to have been deliberately overstating the value of his various real
和邦妮的婚姻已经岌岌可危。几位与邦妮关系密切的人声称，她在被谋杀前的几天里曾公开谈论过与吉姆离婚。据邦妮的记账员说，邦妮曾预约在1990年8月20日星期一，也就是她被杀的前一天晚上，与一位离婚律师见面。经济利益是另一个潜在动机。吉姆一直坚称旅馆在财务上收支平衡，但对他税务记录的审查显示，该业务在1989年至1990年间亏损了550000美元。吉姆还被发现故意夸大了他各种房地产
estate holdings. Although he claimed to be a multimillionaire, in reality he was in a precarious financial position. Not long after purchasing the lodge, Bonnie Hood had received a $250,000 inheritance. The money would have gone a long way in covering the lodge's expenses, but Bonnie refused to put her own money into the business. Rumours had it that this became a major source of contention between the hoods. In the aftermath of Bonnie's murder, Jim was the beneficiary of her $750,000 life insurance policy. It turned out that he'd also collected an additional $2 million from a separate mortgage
资产的价值。虽然他声称自己是千万富翁，但实际上他处于不稳定的财务状况中。在购买旅馆后不久，邦妮·胡德收到了一笔250000美元的遗产。这笔钱本可以在支付旅馆开支方面发挥很大作用，但邦妮拒绝将自己的钱投入到生意中。有传言称这成了胡德夫妇之间争论的主要来源。在邦妮被谋杀后，吉姆是她750000美元人寿保险单的受益人。事实证明，他还从另一份抵押贷款保险单中额外获得了200万美元，
insurance policy that he'd taken out on the lodge, bringing his entire windfall from Bonnie's death to nearly $3 million. With all of this information coming to light, investigators were certain of their long-standing theory that Jim Hood had hired a hitman to kill his wife. Further digging revealed that Bruce Beecham had previously proven himself willing and able to do Jim's dirty work. In 1989, Jim had apparently paid Bruce $9,000 to illegally cut down 35 trees to give passing motorists a better view of a Mission Plaza billboard. The Hitman theory formed the basis of the prosecution's case against Jim Hood when he went to trial in October 1992. Although Jim maintained that he'd killed Bruce Beecham in self-defense, the prosecution
这是他为旅馆投保的，使他从邦妮之死中获得的全部意外之财接近300万美元。随着所有这些信息的曝光，调查人员确信他们长期以来的理论，即吉姆·胡德雇佣了一名杀手来杀害他的妻子。进一步挖掘发现，布鲁斯·比彻姆之前已经证明自己愿意并有能力做吉姆的脏活。1989年，吉姆显然付给布鲁斯9000美元，非法砍伐了35棵树，以便让过往的驾车者能更好地看到使命广场的广告牌。杀手理论构成了1992年10月吉姆·胡德受审时检方案件的基础。尽管吉姆坚称他是出于正当防卫杀死了布鲁斯·比彻姆，但检方
argued that he'd murdered Bruce to bring an end to his extortion efforts. The problem was, investigators hadn't been able to find tangible proof that Bruce had received any money from Jim Hood, aside from his old paychecks from work. The defence accused Sharon and Gary Spray of making their story up so they could file a lawsuit against Jim for Bruce's wrongful death. Although Sharon denied this accusation on the stand, it was revealed that she had already consulted with three separate lawyers about filing such a lawsuit. Jim Hood took the stand in his own defence. He claimed not to know whether Bruce was involved in Bonnie's murder and asserted that any bad blood between the two men stemmed from the theft of his construction equipment and the subsequent prosecution of Gary Spray.
辩称他谋杀布鲁斯是为了结束他的勒索行为。问题是，调查人员除了他以前的工作工资外，无法找到布鲁斯从吉姆·胡德那里收到任何钱的有形证据。辩方指责莎伦和加里·斯普雷编造故事，以便他们可以就布鲁斯的非正常死亡对吉姆提起诉讼。尽管莎伦在证人席上否认了这一指控，但据透露，她已经咨询了三位不同的律师，准备提起此类诉讼。吉姆·胡德亲自出庭为自己辩护。他声称不知道布鲁斯是否参与了邦妮的谋杀案，并断言两人之间的任何积怨都源于他的建筑设备被盗以及随后对加里·斯普雷的起诉。
Jim maintained that he'd invited Bruce to his office to settle their differences peacefully and only gunned Bruce down when Bruce went to shoot him first. It took the jury 20 days to announce that they'd reached a verdict, only to change their mind the following morning and continue deliberations. In the end, they were at an impasse. Ten jurors had settled on guilty verdicts, one believed Jim wasn't guilty, and the remaining juror was undecided. A mistrial was declared, with a retrial scheduled for later in the year. Jim Hood's retrial commenced in September 1993 with the surprising revelation from the judge. He barred the prosecution from presenting any evidence suggesting that Jim had hired Bruce
吉姆坚称他邀请布鲁斯到他的办公室是为了和平解决分歧，只有在布鲁斯先开枪时才开枪打死了布鲁斯。陪审团花了20天时间才宣布他们达成了裁决，结果第二天早上又改变了主意，继续审议。最终，他们陷入了僵局。十名陪审员决定判决有罪，一名认为吉姆无罪，剩下的陪审员未作决定。宣布审判无效，重审定于今年晚些时候进行。吉姆·胡德的重审于1993年9月开始，法官透露了一个令人惊讶的消息。他禁止检方提出任何暗示吉姆雇佣了布鲁斯
Beecham to murder his wife, making it clear that this trial would focus solely on Bruce's murder and not on the murder of Bonnie Hood. The prosecution therefore had no choice but to centre their case around the physical evidence from the crime scene in Jim's office. case around the physical evidence from the crime scene in Jim's office. As for the motive, they could only go so far as to assert that Bruce was attempting to blackmail Jim about something. Jim had already admitted during the first trial that he'd paid Bruce to do illegal work for him in the past. This alone proved that Bruce was in possession of some knowledge that he could use against Jim. Jim Hood took the stand again, but he changed several critical details from his original
·比彻姆谋杀他妻子的证据，明确表示这次审判将仅关注布鲁斯的谋杀案，而不是邦妮·胡德的谋杀案。因此，检方别无选择，只能将他们的案件集中在吉姆办公室犯罪现场的物证上。案件集中在吉姆办公室犯罪现场的物证上。至于动机，他们只能断言布鲁斯试图就某事勒索吉姆。吉姆在第一次审判中已经承认，他过去曾付钱给布鲁斯为他做非法工作。仅此一点就证明布鲁斯掌握了一些可以用来对付吉姆的信息。吉姆·胡德再次出庭，但他改变了最初证词中的几个关键细节。
testimony. In the first trial, Jim claimed that Bruce's hand and head had moved in very specific ways after he'd been shot. During the retrial, however, Jim denied that Bruce had moved at all. In order to show the jury that Jim had changed his story, the prosecution did something they believed had never been done in a California courtroom. They called jurors from the first trial to testify as eyewitnesses to what Jim's original testimony had been. One by one, the former jurors provided irrefutable proof that Jim had purged himself on the stand, completely shattering his credibility. hand, completely shattering his credibility. After six days of deliberation, the second jury returned a unanimous verdict. Jim Hood was found guilty of murdering Bruce Beecham and sentenced to 29 years in prison. Jim continued to maintain his innocence in the murders of both Bruce and Bonnie.
在第一次审判中，吉姆声称布鲁斯的手和头在他被枪杀后以非常具体的方式移动。然而，在重审期间，吉姆否认布鲁斯有任何移动。为了向陪审团展示吉姆改变了说法，检方做了一件他们认为在加州法庭上从未做过的事情。他们传唤了第一次审判的陪审员作为目击者，证明吉姆最初的证词是什么。前陪审员们一个接一个地提供了无可辩驳的证据，证明吉姆在证人席上作了伪证，彻底粉碎了他的可信度。手，彻底粉碎了他的可信度。经过六天的审议，第二个陪审团做出了一致裁决。吉姆·胡德被判谋杀布鲁斯·比彻姆罪名成立，被判处29年监禁。吉姆继续坚称自己在布鲁斯和邦妮的谋杀案中都是无辜的。
His two children stood by him, believing he was wrongfully convicted and falsely accused for both crimes. In 2012, Jim's ongoing claims of innocence cost him the opportunity to be released from prison early due to good behaviour. He was considered a model inmate, having taken courses in stress management and conflict resolution. According to prison officials, Jim never once violated a single prison rule. However, in the words of the state governor, until Jim Hood shows that he has genuinely explored and can give a credible account of the circumstance that led to his killing of Bruce Beecham, I cannot be persuaded that he would not commit future acts of violence if released from prison. The governor's statements demonstrated the catch-22 of prisoners who claimed to be truly
他的两个孩子支持他，认为他被错误定罪，并被虚假指控犯有这两起罪行。2012年，吉姆持续的清白主张使他失去了因表现良好而提前获释的机会。他被认为是一名模范囚犯，参加了压力管理和冲突解决课程。据监狱官员称，吉姆从未违反过任何一条监狱规定。然而，用州长的话说，直到吉姆·胡德表现出他已经真正探索并能对导致他杀害布鲁斯·比彻姆的情况做出可信的解释，我无法被说服他如果获释不会犯下未来的暴力行为。州长的声明展示了声称自己真正
innocent. Jim's refusal to confess meant he remained in prison for a further five years. He was ultimately released in 2017 after serving 23 years and has since kept a low profile. years, and has since kept a low profile. Authorities remain convinced that Bruce Beecham killed Bonnie Hood under Jim's order. In 1996, Bonnie's case was reopened after police received a package claiming to contain new information about her murder. What the package contained, or who sent sent it has never been made public. Upon further investigation, the sheriff determined the new information wasn't enough to officially close the case. As of 2024, the murder of Bonnie Hood officially remains unsolved. When 18-year-old Neyam May went missing in 2002, her family did everything they could
无辜的囚犯所面临的困境。吉姆拒绝认罪意味着他在监狱里又多待了五年。他最终在服刑23年后于2017年获释，此后一直保持低调。年，此后一直保持低调。当局仍然确信布鲁斯·比彻姆是在吉姆的命令下杀害了邦妮·胡德。1996年，在警方收到一个声称包含有关她谋杀案新信息的包裹后，邦妮的案件被重新开启。包裹里装了什么，或者谁寄的，从未公开过。经过进一步调查，警长确定新信息不足以正式结案。截至2024年，邦妮·胡德的谋杀案正式仍未侦破。当18岁的尼娅姆·梅在2002年失踪时，她的家人尽其所能
to help the police find her. But like so many missing persons cases, there comes a time when the leads dry up and there's nowhere left to look. At no point have we just got on with our lives. I heard something recently that really resonated. It was a woman from America who said that you never get over grief, you learn to move forward with it and I was like that's the best anyone's ever described it. Niamh's sister, Fionnuala, realised that a podcast might help find the answers the family was looking for. So for
帮助警察找到她。但像许多失踪人员案件一样，总会有一个线索枯竭、无处可寻的时候。我们从来没有一刻只是继续我们的生活。我最近听到了一些真正引起共鸣的话。那是一位来自美国的女性，她说你永远无法克服悲伤，你学会带着它继续前进，我就想，这是任何人描述得最好的方式。尼娅姆的妹妹菲奥努拉意识到，播客可能有助于找到家人正在寻找的答案。所以过去
the past four years I've been working with Nehems family to take a closer look at the case and what we found took us to places we never anticipated. Here's everything we've done. We've obviously got serious concerns about her welfare. I've just spoken to the last person to see her alive that we knew about and he's given me a bullshit story. When I first started looking into this case in 2020, it was originally intended to be a single case file episode.
四年里，我一直与尼娅姆的家人合作，更深入地研究这个案子，我们发现的东西把我们带到了我们从未预料到的地方。这是我们所做的一切。我们显然对她的安危有严重的担忧。我刚刚和我们所知的最后一个见到她活着的人谈过，他给了我一个胡说八道的故事。当我2020年第一次开始调查这个案子时，它最初打算成为一个单一的案件档案剧集。
But the more I looked, the more I found. So Steve, he's adamant that she never made it to Go Cup Road. Stan is adamant that there's a credible sighting there. Niamh set out for a gap year after finishing high school to test her independence, but she never made it home. What happened in those final days? And when the Blackhurst arrived, these two men got out and as soon as I saw them and I saw that Blackhurst, I thought, they're baddiesdies stay away from them. Mum called me and she said, look, the police are investigating now
但我看得越多，发现的就越多。所以史蒂夫，他坚信她从未到达过Go Cup路。斯坦坚信那里有一个可信的目击点。尼娅姆在高中毕业后开始了一年的间隔年，以测试她的独立性，但她从未回家。那些最后几天发生了什么？当Blackhurst到达时，这两个人下来了，我一看到他们，看到那辆Blackhurst，我就想，他们是坏蛋，离他们远点。妈妈给我打电话，她说，看，警察现在正在调查
and somebody claims that they dropped her off and that she was hitchhiking. What started out as a potential case file episode turned into a 12-part series that took over four years to research. He didn't smile or anything, he just kind of looked empty and just like get in the car. It was just kind of like aggressively like get in the car.
有人声称他们送她下车，而且她当时在搭便车。最初可能成为案件档案剧集的内容变成了一个12部分的系列，花了四年多的时间进行研究。他没有笑什么的，他只是看起来很空洞，就像“上车”。这就像是一种侵略性的“上车”。
Join me as we uncover what happened in Missing Neham, the new 12 part podcast series from Casefile Presents. Something that obviously woken me suddenly because I was disorientated. That's when I realised that there was just a cold, rough hand holding my hand because I had my hand over the edge of the bed. And I could see the outline of somebody leaning over the bed. Eva, I guess, has to be somewhat attractive, doesn't it?
加入我，让我们揭开Missing Neham中发生了什么，这是来自Casefile Presents的全新12部分播客系列。有些事情显然突然把我惊醒了，因为我感到迷失方向。就在那时，我意识到有一只冰冷、粗糙的手握着我的手，因为我的手放在床边。我可以看到有人弯腰在床上的轮廓。伊娃，我想，必须有点吸引力，不是吗？
Otherwise, I wouldn't be able to sneak into every corner. So I whispered to my sister, asked her if she was awake, and said yes. I said there's someone in the room and she said I know. Missing Nehem is available now. Be sure to download and follow Missing Nehem wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
否则，我就无法潜入每一个角落。所以我对我的妹妹耳语，问她是否醒着，她说是的。我说房间里有人，她说我知道。Missing Neham现在可以收听了。请务必在您获取播客的任何地方下载并关注Missing Neham。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。